Rumer Willis is touching tribute to her  dancing partner with a new season of  Dancing with the Stars quickly  approaching reigning champ Rumer Willis  penned a sweet thank-you note to her pro  partner Val Chmerkovskiy on Instagram  Wednesday in the lengthy post which was  attached to an adorable photo collage  rumor thanked Val for a few reasons one  for being an amazing teacher always  challenging her to be a better dancer  and two for believing in her even when  she didn't believe in herself Val  returned the favor posting his own note  to rumor on his account reminding her it  isn't the end just the beginning  love you champ et caught up with rumor  in July who said the benefits of doing  Dancing with the Stars went far beyond  the surface I hope that affected some  sort of change in that sense with  hopefully setting a better example for  young girls or trying to figure out how  to navigate going into your body and  figuring out who you are and not be so  judgmental